I want to talk about something that I'm
interested in as a human being okay now
I don't know if you a lot of you know
this I'm sure you know it but I'm a big
I'm really into astronomy I love
astronomy I think that's been well
estate yeah that's my thing
yeah thank you Andy thank you you're
welcome well recently I was perusing one
of my many astronomy news feeds and a
certain story caught my eye this is true
I thought this was really interesting a
big space crash likely made Uranus
lopsided which I thought was an
interesting story I did not know that
Uranus was lotsa yeah no no apparently
apparently it is all right well everyone
that's that's Toni it's one of our
cameramen Toni what's so funny
Uranus that's right
Toni scientists say that it's a lot of
time okay so let me get this straight
Conan you're telling me that Uranus is
lopsided yes it is it sure is Toni
according to the article and I'm as
surprised as you are by this okay okay
all right hold on just a sec here I know
I ain't exactly the brightest bulb in
the toolbox but you're telling me the
jury knows your names
yeah Tony which up until now I've been
thought to be completely symmetrical
he's infected that's right Tony Uranus
is lopsided what'd you say about my anus
no no Tony we're talking about Uranus
the planet - ain't no planet you take
that back no one is calling Uranus the
planet Tony calm down he'll calm down
Richter I will not stand here and let
him call my anus a lopsided planet I
have a great I have a great hey Tony
Tony Tony I'm sorry I'm sorry for what I
said about Uranus okay no problem Conan
but don't we favor can you just you know
say the thing yes Tony my anus is
lopsided this segment brought to you by
the double entendre Council of America
additional funding provided by the
freakin various foundations semen
spotted dick the Louis monsters
warehouse of petrified wood and pitched
tents salami that's right just some
unease in general with Georgia O'Keeffe
museum and penis and booties
International
very proud of myself